في السنوات الاخيره كانت موجه من
التكنولوجيا تحاول التنبؤ بشكل افضل
بالكوارث مثل الفيضانات وامواج تسونامي
والزلازل ترتبط هذه الموجه بشكل كبير
بالذكاء الاصطناعي يستخدم الباحثون
خوارزميات التعلم العميق لغربله ضوضاء
المدينه بحيث يمكن جمع بيانات الزلازل
بشكل افضل اي انها تعتمد على تحليل جميع
الموجات الصوتيه والزلزاليه على عكس
التقنيات السابقه التي تقوم بانتقاء اصوات
معينه لتسجيلها وتحليلها وجد الباحثون ان
الموجات الصوتيه التي تصدر اثناء الانزلاق
البطيء للصفائح الارضيه ترتبط بشكل دقيق
بحاله الضغط الذي تتعرض له هذه الصفائح
وبالزمن المتبقي قبل تصدعها وحدوث الزلزال
يقول الباحثون ان هذه الطريقه يمكنها
تحديد الزمن المتبقي لحدوث الزلزال مع
هامش خطا لا يتجاوز 10% لكن هذا الهامش
يتقلص الى اثنين ونصف في المئه مع اقتراب
لحظه حدوث الزلزال
[موسيقى]